It's school time!
No wonder that many of us
They are determined to study acumen instead of studying for a long time.
But no tips and tricks study
He works scientifically,
Can you help you get full scores?
The first step, research proved that the study sessions
They are more effective when broken down into small, short parts.
Instead of stuffing your mind with information for ten hours in one session,
Of the most effective division
To sessions of twenty or thirty minutes over a few weeks.
This is because your mind works better
In coding information with neural connections
In short, repetitive sessions unlike a long study session.
So, even learning different skills,
Whether he studied swimming, tennis, or singing
This method is often applied.
While studying and staying up all night
It may be a reduction,
But it turned out to be associated with the lowest scores.
After long night study sessions,
Your thinking and memory may be negatively affected
For a full four days.
Instead, create specific times per day,
Or during the week, only to study
Bring your mind through the creation of a routine
Over time, the study becomes easier,
Because your mind is trained to study at those moments.
While many of us spend hours
To read our memoirs in a negative way or to identify the important things in the book,
Studies have proven that this is ineffective.
This does not improve your understanding of the topics.
And does not link key concepts together.
It may even have a harmful effect,
It attracts your interest to less important information.
On the other hand, memorizing cards,
Installed as excellent tools to enhance memory
Whether you read it during your scheduled study times,
Or during your free time; for example, while you are on the bus home.
It is also useful to have a specific goal
Per study session.
Instead of studying in a random way,
Select an aspect to focus on
Whether balancing chemical equations,
Or learn how to conduct French verbs.
If you can not explain the subject in a simplified way,
It means you do not understand the subject well.
A study was conducted where requested
Of individuals reading a piece
Then half of them were told
That they will test about the piece,
While the other half were told
That they would have to teach them to other students
Participants who are taught,
They did a good job of understanding key points.
When education requires you,
Your mind regulates information
In a more coherent and logical manner.
Of course...
training! training! training!
Do not train on tests and focus your mind in the atmosphere of tests,
Even if mistakes were made,
It will help you identify gaps in your knowledge.
Studies have also proven that training on tests
Boosts confidence,
As a result it performs better.
So, where should you study?
Studies have proven that owning a place
A single study,
Well equipped,
Each tool you may need is the most appropriate place.
Just as the times were created,
This brings your mind to study.
Do you have an amazing playlist to study?
Slow down a bit.
While some studies have proven that
Some types of classical music are selected
Can help to increase focus,
However, a recent study has shown that
Study while listening to rhythmic sounds in the background
It can be distracted to focus
And those who did not listen to music
Think better.
If you have not already done so,
Put your phone aside!
This does not require deep reflection,
But your text message messages and social networking sites
Decrease your concentration significantly.
Of course, the tests can be worrisome,
So if you want some advice
About how to deal with anxiety tests
Watch the video on our other channel ASAP Thought
Which offers some tips on the subject.
Link in description
A big thank to TD Bank
To take care of this video.
If you go to school this fall,
Click the link below,
Or visit ...
... to see how TD can help you
Start the school with a plan.
Know how much it can be
Buying books and paying bills is difficult
The TD has great solutions for you.
Be sure to watch it.
Subscribe to more weekly science videos.